la parole est à monsieur philippe paul
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre garot
monsieur le ministre vendredi le
tribunal de commerce de rennes a validé
le plan de continuation de l'activité de
la société gad actant du même coup la
fermeture de l'abattoir de
lampaul-guimiliau et la disparition de
889 emplois le lendemain la presse
locale évoquait la possible sinon
probable
suppression de 80 emplois par la société
jean caby toujours à lampaul-guimiliau
en un très court laps de temps ce sont
près de 1000 emplois qui sont ainsi
supprimées dans cette commune de 2000
habitants plongeant de très nombreuses
familles et toute une population dans
une profonde détresse
après la suppression de 1000 emplois
chez doux puis de 400 chez marine
harvest l'hécatombe se poursuit dans
l'agroalimentaire finistérien
monsieur le ministre hier à l'issue de
la réunion d'urgence qui s'est tenue à
matignon des mesures de soutien ont été
confirmés aux salariés de la société gad
à travers le contrat de sécurisation
professionnelle
des salariés qui n'ont jamais ménagé
leurs efforts pour faire une entreprise
dont il était fier et dont l'actionnaire
principal la cecab laisse aujourd'hui
brutalement au bord du chemin
cette nécessaire solidarité ne va pas en
rester là au delà de l'accompagnement
des salariés privés d'emploi dans le
cadre de tonnes cette tragédie
industrielle il en va de l'avenir de
tout un territoire je m'associe à ce
sujet à la demande du président du
conseil régional de bretagne de
moratoire de l'écotaxe s'il est maintenu
ce nouvel impôt ne conduira qu'à
affaiblir encore un peu plus l'économie
d'une région excentrée
déjà pénalisés géographiquement la
sagesse et la raison commande de
réserver une suite favorable à cette
demande de moratoire il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
l'égalité des territoires ne doit pas
être une veine formule il est de la
responsabilité de l'état de mettre tout
en oeuvre pour soutenir la bretagne et
sa pointe occidentale pour les
accompagner dans l'épreuve qu'elle
traverse
aussi en complément des mesures
annoncées hier prévoyez-vous la mise en
place sur les bassins d'emploi
sévèrement touchés comme celui du pays
de landivisiau de contrat de site
mobilisant état collectivités
territoriales chambres consulaires à
même de contribuer à les adapter allait
revitaliser et à redonner enfin l'espoir
en l'avenir
plus précisément pouvez vous nous
détailler la forme de l'engagement de
l'état auprès de la communauté de
communes du pays de landi vision qui
vient de demander à la cecab la cession
de la propriété du site de lampaul
guimiliau et ce afin de favoriser
l'arrivée d'un repreneur et la relance
de l'outil je vous remercie merci
monsieur philippe paul
la parole est à monsieur guillaume garot
ministre chargé de l'agroalimentaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur vous avez
raison c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
bretagne en tout cas certaines filières
et surtout certains territoires de cette
région bretagne traverse une période
extrêmement difficile et douloureuse en
particulier pour les salariés des
entreprises comme gad qui sont
aujourd'hui sur le carreau à lampaul
guimiliau alors il est de notre
responsabilité à nous
gouvernants de pouvoir apporter des
réponses des réponses qu'ils soient
concrètes mais des réponses qui
souhaitent aussi durable et c'est le
sens du pacte d'avenir pour la bretagne
qui a présenté hier le premier ministre
ce pack qui sera mis en oeuvre sans
tarder il sera finalisé avant la fin de
l'année au terme d'une mobilisation que
nous voulons très large en bretagne avec
l'ensemble des forces vives de la région
alors concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut
dire que répondre à l'urgence d'abord ça
veut dire
accompagner les salariés qui sont
licenciés dans les entreprises que vous
avez évoqué je pense à gad en
particulier ça veut dire ce contrat de
sécurisation professionnelle qui fait
bénéficier à chaque
salariés qui en ferait la demande
évidemment d'un maintien quasiment à
100% du salaire net pendant un an et
durant cette période d'un an un vrai
accompagnement pour la formation pour la
reconversion en même temps qu'une aide
tout à fait direct pour la recherche
d'emploi
ça c'est la première chose et c'est une
façon tout à fait tangibles de marquer
la solidarité de l'état mais il faut
aller plus loin et nous nous sommes
d'ores et déjà employé avec stéphane le
foll en particulier à mobiliser les
entreprises du bassin large autour de
lampaul et en particulier des
entreprises du bassin du secteur
alimentaire pour voir quelles sont les
possibilités d'accueil
donc les possibilités de reclassement
dans ces entreprises pour les salariés
qui sont aujourd'hui licencié à lampaul
voilà comment la solidarité concrète
peut aujourd'hui s'organiser et puis il
faut préparer l'avenir et il ya une
première mesure que qu'a annoncé aussi
ici le premier ministre avec la mise à
disposition en tout cas une session
favoriser pour la communauté de communes
que le recul du site du site de gad à
lampaul grâce à l'établissement public
foncier régional c'est comme ça que nous
allons avancer et puis au delà de ça et
je terminerai pas là il nous faut
préparer l'avenir ça veut dire activer
les outils que outils que sont la banque
publique d'investissement le programme
investissements d'avenir pour permettre
que on appuie l'investissement
l'innovation l'exportation des
entreprises alimentaires en bretagne il
ya un magnifique potentiel et nous
croyons tous ici à l'avenir de la
bretagne à travers ce grand secteur
économique je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre